all right i want to let you know that i
got some tour dates coming up savannah
georgia
june 2nd
augusta georgia june 3rd
montgomery alabama june 4
and columbus georgia june 5.
as well i'll be in florida
hollywood fort myers daytona beach and
lakeland
june 23rd through june 26th
today's guest is here for the first time
he's a comedian and he's an entertaining
man
and he is out of new york
and um you're going to learn about him
as i do he and i have actually never met
but he has a new special on youtube
called mom love
and his own podcast called long days
i'm grateful to get to spend some time
with him
uh ladies and gentlemen mr yanus papas
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
and i will find a song
[Applause]
yeah you know what i've been realizing
is uh
what's dicey to me is if they get those
little
sandwiches you know the ones um the
little
man uh cut sandwiches
yeah
you know what i'm saying somebody wrote
cut up
no no but more like just like the square
ones and then somebody cuts it up like
that you know what i'm talking about
like the triangle piece conceptually i
know i'm trying to picture it though so
yeah it just says meat cheese man and
mustard or mayonnaise in it yeah it just
like is a little triangle yeah you know
somebody gets a little round tray of a
bunch of those little triangles yes now
i got you yeah
but then the weird part is when they
start to sit there for a while and it
gets hard on the side and people still
eat them yeah
that's why you got to get to that plate
early but it's some guys prefer air
damage yes some guys prefer to go into
the tray
late in the game bro
yeah that's not the way you got to get
there before the air damage brightens it
up yeah yeah that is air damage man yeah
there's a triangular yeah you know what
i'm talking about those triangular ones
are you talking about they come in like
a plastic plate you pull it off yes
i know exactly what you're talking about
yeah they got the top on it yeah um
convenient way to throw a party
yeah yeah you don't got to make
sandwiches if you if you know it's just
yeah better that way yeah i think having
it like that is probably makes things uh
yeah somebody cracks open and thinking
of those as a kid i hate this i was like
oh those things look like they're for
adults or something
but as an adult i'm like i'll have a one
or two of those yeah
they're nice yeah it's a perfect you
can't go back you can't go wrong with
meat and cheese at an adult party meat
and cheese is always a hit salami and
cheese yeah that's always that's gonna
go first yeah people aren't gonna touch
the salad people aren't gonna touch if
you got the carrots and the ranch out
those will be there tomorrow the whole
plate will be there but yeah the salami
and cheese is gone yeah yeah it's the
beyonce of that spread
man
um
is janice's mic in his face guys do you
guys want it somewhere different i
always have mic problems i apologize do
you i do it's something like even on my
own podcast or like
uh like i just can't i have no i i might
be challenged in that way like a
learning disability with like where the
mic is supposed to be yeah
yeah i think it does get to be like uh
um i'm either too low too high yeah
but you've been uh you've been
podcasting for a long time um so a lot
of my listeners might not even know you
and you and i have just met we just met
yeah yeah and that's crazy yeah well i
know you you know yeah
yeah like i know you've comedy but yeah
it's the first time we've been in the
flesh yeah yeah it feels good it's
interesting yeah you got a cozy warm
kind of vibe yeah energy oh thanks yeah
i feel i feel right like in the womb i'm
i feel in a womb you're good yeah i like
it man yeah yeah well thanks for coming
man so i want to just like kind of just
so my listeners know like how you even
got started like in the comedy just take
me through a little bit of that man
because you are from
another country
i'm from another country are you from
another country i'm uh america oh
yeah i thought you were well it would
technically be right if you were from
if you weren't from here right and i
would be from another country but were
you born in another country no i was
born here oh i thought you were born in
another country i dude i look at you and
i i say i can see why he would assume
that because you're [ __ ] american
yeah you're american-american like if
there can be
more of a way to be american yeah it's
on you so i know just hearing my name
you're like i guess he's from he must
have been born in romania or something i
got an immigrant name
yeah i would i mean i don't know if i
would i remember um
i said to one of my friends yesterday i
was like oh uh giannis pappas is coming
on and they're like oh i thought
um
oh who's the they're like oh that
reminds me of that guy who has the other
name that's kind of like a double oh um
who's the russian guy the older russian
jewish comedian
uh zielinski he's fighting a war right
now no i'm not that guy
oh he's ukrainian same [ __ ] he's doing
cameos somebody said that's crazy yeah i
mean for 600 to raise money for ukraine
that's crazy that is crazy and he's got
time
where do they have that guy that he's
got a camera set up and i tell you one i
don't know who his barber is but he's on
call the dude is always crisp in the
middle of a war i mean he's got like a
fade every three days oh yeah he's like
the dj khaled i feel like of like
bombings yeah i think he just travels
with his barber
he's got a barber in the bomb shelter he
really values whoever cuts his hair and
dude will somebody win this [ __ ] war
already like jesus
what
it feels like they just nobody will win
it or they don't care or they taking
days off it feels like they're like hey
let's do it on tuesday i'll meet you
guys on friday we'll do another round on
friday it is hard to understand right
because like
if there's a war going on how is he safe
to
give talks and you know do a video zoom
for the oscars and then biden goes there
he's walking around no problem i think
nancy pelosi yeah was wheeled out there
so like where's the war
yeah i don't know what's happening yeah
and i don't know i think it's like a i
think they got to go to court like maybe
johnny and amber to solve it figure it
out yeah cause i'm [ __ ] who's bad
son yeah i feel like johnny is russia in
this scenario
and amber uh no i'm sorry johnny yeah
johnny's johnny's ukraine i'm sorry and
amber's russia
and uh no
yeah who's the best there's only two
ways to do it i don't know it's only two
the good guys are ukraine i'm trying to
depend on it depends on which side of
the political aisle you i guess you fall
on to consider who's the bad guy yeah
but i think
johnny yeah is ukraine johnny because he
got invaded by amber
so we need to figure out ways to funnel
weapons to johnny yeah that's what we
got to do to help out johnny
yeah i saw johnny depp one night at the
comedy store it was pretty crazy that is
a crazy sighting to see johnny because i
went up and
dug stand up as friends when they
introduced me to him and then i realized
i didn't know what to say and then i
realized i didn't have anything to say
to johnny that right
that's almost the worst but like when
you're like oh there's not even there's
not even a 30th degree of separation
like
there's nothing to even say here it's
like literally shook hands and then
i had nothing
yeah
i it would kind it's kind of similar to
meeting you because what i wanted to say
i held it maybe what you wanted to say
you held it because you felt like he's
he's over it like i would have opened
with a 21 jump street thing because
that's my closest emotional tie to
johnny okay was his hair back then with
the earring he kind of said that that my
generation pull that picture up with
johnny depp 21 jump street let's get an
image of that i think he was like the
that hairstyle with the earring was like
every white guy in america did that
middle part with the earring and so i
would open with a 21 jump street like
with you i wrote rules but i didn't want
to say it i know you're from road rules
i remember oh that's interesting yeah
and you're as big as i thought you were
like tall you're a tall drink of water
uh you know it's really funny people say
that i'm tall and i don't i don't i've
always just been
i mean i've been this hype for probably
21 years now and it's like
i don't think anything i never thought i
was tall but people constantly say that
yeah you're six months man bro you're
taller than i thought
so it's always mexican you comment on it
you know i'm not gonna say that
but it's a lot of like uh latinos you
know or recent americans
who are like
i thought
recent american is a better way than to
call mexican it's a way to scoot around
it well not even mexican but just i feel
like if we're gonna be
because people remember that people used
to say illegal immigrants right yeah
because i'll meet a lot of mexican guys
and be like uh
you know where did you come or how did
you you know and they were like uh just
don't tell anybody i'm here you know
what i'm saying they all joke about it
yeah yeah yeah you know yeah but it's
like so i think recent americans yeah it
at least gives both sides of the net
likes a little bit of like
okay
they're new and then other people like
yeah let's you know you're running cover
for them because you're not lying right
but you're also not telling them they
may not have their papers they're recent
americans interpret that the way you
wanted to
we got a couple recent americans here
god johnny depp was just man yeah oh
yeah he'd be a hot chick now even he
yeah if he went trans he would look good
some guys you can tell if they
transition they would flawlessly
transition usually they don't have the
like the neo underthrow brow that's a
real impediment to like a smooth
transition but he got a real nice girl
guy face oh yeah god man yeah if he put
some makeup on and grew the hair a
little longer i don't even think he'd
need estrogen
well he's a handsome kid he's handsome
guy yeah and he used to definitely be
more i mean look he's getting older you
know and i think he's partied pretty
hard he's probably going pretty hard
yeah
yeah for a guy who did the amount of
drugs he did yeah he looks good that's a
good point he looks real good that's a
good point i mean i don't know how much
la has to do with that hollywood people
with uh who are stars tend to age very
well because i guess when your job is
just staying in shape every day in
between scripts yeah you dedicate a lot
of time to it there's like a team of
people who keep johnny tap like camera
ready well you can also get flu you got
fluffers that's a big thing yeah like a
guy that's going to do work at dunkin
donuts or whatever he ain't got that
fluffy you know what i'm saying he don't
have somebody meeting him in the parking
lot an hour early yeah to polish him up
and trim off all the loose ends and take
his up his dirty appendix out or
whatever is going on you know
but he's got those people where every
day before he you know those people like
just really shining them up you think
like if there was a competitor to come
out that would compete against dunkin
donuts and starbucks if they use the
strategy of like you know what
we're gonna up the game of the people
who work here and make them all
beautiful with fluffers will hire
fluffers too that they'll that'll even
if the coffee's not as good it'll give
them the edge like how come nobody's
thinking outside the box like that
well so you're saying if they beautified
the um
the staff the staff yeah with fluff with
the help of fluffers if they got the
corporate money right they can create
extra jobs we don't have to live in this
world where coffee shops have like ugly
untaken care of i don't know if that's
the way you say it unquaffed unkempt
yeah unkept unkept people maybe we need
to create jobs how about how about a
couple fluffers for these dunkin donuts
employees yeah cinderella's sisters are
you who you're talking about yeah that's
exactly what it is um well look at this
you know i was at the starbucks the
other day and a guy runs in homeless guy
right yeah
i'm not gonna say homeless but the guy
was
the guy hadn't heard a doorbell ring in
a while i bet right recently unhomed i
would say that yeah i would say recently
the american recently
so this boy he was out there and uh he
came in he had no pants on right
and he walked past these two chicks
outside and they got a little scared you
know and i was like scat scat like i did
like that you know cause like uh we had
a lot of stray animals in our
neighborhood growing up and if they came
by my sisters i would be like that did
he respond did he eat scat or what kind
of did he get working on it yeah yeah
yeah he kind of did and then he went
inside and stole all of the
money right out of the tip thing he did
yeah and um so the scat
you were like an accessory to the crime
then we didn't tell him to scout he
would have bothered the girls and
may not have he could have done a rape
and burgle oh yeah it's hard to know
what would have happened right that
could have been the lesser of the two
evils
well then i go in and there's a guy in
there who's like
very who's like probably about 11
different genders right this dude was
coming in you know he had anchovies he
had all of it
and he um
he was like oh my god i don't know what
just happened right
and i was like y'all got [ __ ] robbed
that's what just happened bro and nobody
in here they had 11 of them and how is
it they have 11 starbuck employees they
all have on walkie-talkies talking to
each other right next to each other yeah
it doesn't seem like they need that yeah
you could just go like this it's like
ordering a sandwich at wawa's you're
like why can't i just give it the order
to you why do i gotta become a computer
programmer back here yeah it's
unnecessary technology oh a lot of
unnecessary technology and so
then uh yeah but it was just crazy they
were everybody was just so like
like nobody there could have saved the
day right you know because actually they
had this one little mighty mouse [ __ ]
you know i think if she'd have seen it
go down she wouldn't she was dealing
with an egg mc you know day breakfast or
something but the moment when that thing
when the guy hit but if she'd have
freaking turned around she was a little
less hungry she might have
took her focus off the order and helped
well she you could just tell she had a
little bit more nuts in her than any of
the uh fellas that were working in right
right they don't care right they don't
care but it was the tips though
uh oh they care about that
but i woulda yeah yeah that's my money
like you know nobody stopped them no the
guy was just like one guy this is the
best one dude
who probably was at least you know
four or five different genders right
this dude coming in bruh you know this
was a non-binary establishment
this dude had his hands up like this
like what the [ __ ]
and the guy didn't have a gun but he did
have his pants off well he had i'll say
this bro he was short and he it looked
like he had a little bit of dick hanging
out the bottom of his shirt and that is
a that's a weapon too
it could be a weapon especially if you
don't know what gender you are yeah bro
you don't know how that thing is going
to end up in you would you be more
scared if a guy with a gun or a guy a
naked guy is kind of
you don't know what to do with a naked
guy easy oh if i had to i'd get the
bullets out of them you know what i'm
saying
i'd handle them down to keep the
pressure out of them if i had to
you ever seen those videos where like
the like those prank shows in the hood
where the guys talk [ __ ] to like tough
dudes in the hood and the guy's like
what and he's about to and then they
just strip naked and the guy runs for
some reason
because i guess it's so jarring you
don't know what to do when somebody's
missing
a piece of their uh outfit it's just
kind of a weird thing i guess shirt off
is more socially
well shirt off we're gonna fight yeah
sheriff's we're gonna fight pants off or
we we're gonna we may i might [ __ ] you
so that gets a little
that's probably what makes you nervous
it's a novelty of it no frame of
reference like when the indians first
saw the boats they couldn't tell what
they were really yeah they said they
didn't they had no frame of reference
for the conquistador boat so they just
couldn't almost see them they couldn't
see them they couldn't understand it it
was like an object they'd never seen so
if you get into a situation when a guy
with no pants and he's threatening you
you might not even understand it and
just free maybe put maybe that's why she
put her hands up yeah maybe she didn't
know she was like is this what you're
supposed to do yeah when a guy has no
pants on a little bit of dick hanging
out under the shirt he had a short shirt
on too
he was a black guy too which is an
unusual shirt yeah because usually they
got long shirts on if you go to a black
barbecue they down to their knees oh
yeah yeah black guys like long shirts
yeah black guys look good and stuff they
look good in everything anything yeah
you know uh black guys look good and
a black guy could walk around literally
just with with shopping tags hang that's
why i think a lot of black guys keep the
tags on things because i think
other people will literally come up and
shop off of them
you know
yeah
damn let me scan this up right now bro
that's not a bad idea bruh it's not a
bad if you got a percentage of the sale
yeah it's like damn let me scan two of
those off of my boy and then he makes a
little bit of bread yeah i i had a black
friend who used to wear his hat like
that with the stickers and tags and we
were having a conversation once and he
was like you know his cops got to stop
profiling me i'm like well maybe if it
looks if you make it look a little less
like you just stole the hat out of the
store yeah you're wearing it like you
just ran out past the sensors
i mean maybe that'll help
yeah they had a blanket i saw with a
chain made out of sensors
that's not gonna that's not helpful
that's actually a good move if you want
to steal a store if you come in with
the sensors on and they're going off
you're going no that's just my necklace
yeah don't look through my don't don't
profile me that's my necklace going off
these are sensors
that's pretty cool
i think i think if someone was cool
enough they could make sensors cool
yeah like you know like because fashion
gets pretty ridiculous
like if you look back in like the 1700s
guys were wearing other dudes [ __ ]
hair and stockings wow and candy corn
shoes so that and that just objectively
looks ridiculous but that means at some
point there was some dude who was so
cool who was wearing it that everyone
was like i want to be like him so they
started wearing [ __ ] ridiculous
stockings candy corn shoes and somebody
else's hair which is some real serial
killer [ __ ] and then the whole continent
of europe started doing it so if there
was a cool enough dude who started
wearing sensors and gave it value like
bitcoin which we all buy which we know
is stupid then i think people would
follow it depends on how [ __ ] cool
the person is wearing it
fashion is completely subjective
yeah i never thought about that that
much i mean
yeah i think if you see somebody with
something and you feel like it looks
good
then if somebody else does it you'll
you'll kind of get into it you know yeah
like i'm not even lying this is a true
story i saw a dude the other day he had
a mullet and somebody else said you're
going with the theo vaughn and he was
like damn everyone keep saying that i'm
like maybe you are consciously or
unconsciously there's very few dudes in
this country
who have a mullet still right that
aren't at a state fair right right you
know what i mean
who are visible yeah yeah like visible
beyond the local
word of mouth right right you're
physical with you're you're visible with
a mullet past word of mouth yeah yeah
and so if somebody has a mall now you're
going like you're you're theo what are
you doing here yeah yeah you're a theo
fan yeah i got into it man i had it
growing up and then i got out of it
trying to fit in hollywood and then i
got back into it it's the best choice
i've ever made have you ever had long
hair i have had long hair but more of
the johnny depp 21 jump street [ __ ] but
you never read the back go huh nah dude
i grew up in brooklyn you can't you
could
you can't i don't have the balls yeah i
was like that was it's well dude it's
like having balls
it's your ball it's like your hair has
balls it's exactly what it's like yeah
have you ever said that before
no but that is the funny let the
funniest way to describe a mullet
because yeah it's like your hair it's
like there's balls here and they're kind
of they're dangling around you can move
them a little bit and there's power in
it yeah well that's the thing there's
[ __ ] power in it there is right i
want to let you guys know about uh a
company that helped me out when i was
trying to buy a home about a year ago
i had some dings on my credit and and i
had to get those taken off
so that i could apply for the mortgage
gave me a better credit score
bridge credit solutions helped me do it
they are backed with a hundred percent
money back guarantee for any items that
cannot be removed you will not find that
anywhere else in the credit repair
industry you know exactly what you're
paying for at the beginning of the
repair it's written in the contract
no job is too big or too small bridge
credit solutions caters to all types of
clients no matter their financial
situation and bridge credit solutions
prides itself on lightning quick
turnaround time they will guarantee
removal of certain
negative items in as quick as 24 hours
that's that is real quick
they take communication seriously always
feel free to call or text no matter the
hour with whatever questions or concerns
you have schedule your free credit audit
in three easy steps zoom or phone call
and get a free three bureau credit
report 25 value with 30 days of free
credit monitoring and identity theft
protection when you sign up through our
link
at bridge
credit solutions dot com slash t-h-e-o
once scheduled a bridge credit
strategist will contact you to review
your report with you
you know i was uh
sometimes you get subscriptions to
things and you don't realize you have a
long-term subscription
you know you get you buy yourself a dang
bagel box or something
and you just wanted one bagel box and
then they keep sending you the bagel
bash every month and then you're just
bashed out with bagels and they keep
charging your credit card
you know i had a thing where i
accidentally i got me a
extension cord and i didn't realize i
signed up for unlimited unlimited
extension cords and damn next thing you
know i just have dumped so many
extension cords i can't even
all my plugins are full you know and
only have damn two lamps
that's where truebill helped me out
with true bill you can enter your
accounts in the true bill and it'll
monitor them
for you and make sure that you're not
getting jacked up and jazzed over
that's right truebill is the new app
that helps you identify and stop paying
for subscriptions you don't need want or
you simply forgot about
on average people save up to seven
hundred and twenty dollars a year with
true bill
that's true and your true bill concierge
is there when you need them to cancel
unwanted subscriptions so you don't have
to that's nice
trouble has over 2 million users and has
helped save them over 100 million
dollars
don't fall for subscription scams start
canceling today
at
truebill.com t-h-e-o
go right now truebill.com
theo it could save you thousands a year
truebill.com
theo
so i just want to get where you started
man yeah and i didn't mean to offend you
if i said that you're from another
country man no i didn't i thought that
you were from another country no did you
think i was offended i wasn't offended
at all okay good yeah yeah i was i was
wrong with it yeah because i get it um
no i was i was i'm from new york my
parents are from another country okay
there so yeah i'm i'm kind of recently
american okay as well i fit into that
category if we open up the bubble a
little bit
cause uh my mom had to get her papers oh
she did yeah my mom had to get her
papers and where did she come from she
came from greece
yeah really grace did you have greeks
down there's no greeks down louis we
never had a greek here
we never on the show never yeah never
dude we've had a we got a charter who
you know
other people we have put pens and
replaced from a different country people
come from
well i'm glad to diversify that yeah i'm
glad yeah man represent for a whole
nation there's not uh
so your mother came from greece my
mother came here uh she was like kind of
a refugee after world war ii my mother
was old she had me when she was in her
40s which is a real today [ __ ] thing to
do she did it back then and uh so she
just recently passed away but she yeah
she was there during the nazi occupation
and
she was there uh yeah for world war ii
and then she immigrated here so my
mother was born there my father was born
in brooklyn but his parents were born
over there in the old world as we call
it wow as white people call it the old
world yeah yeah europe you know
so i'm a one and a half
a first generation i'm a recent i'm a
recent i'm recently american damn so you
weren't you weren't a hundred percent
wrong you weren't 100 right you were
more right than wrong oh thanks yeah
yeah i mean you you you smelled
something
well i just and i think it's probably
yeah just the name people are like oh
what's going on here yeah you know
i don't know you i'm thinking black guy
yeah linebacker
something
cause vaughn
boom and then i see you theo vaughn your
name doesn't seem very
doesn't match you either where does your
name come from well my father's from
nicaragua my mother's from actually um
illinois
so
your mother's wow nicaragua was in there
so we got um
and yeah and then my father was part i
think pontiac indian as well so we had
some good you know something a little
bit here and there kind of you know
should we the pontiac car is catching no
heat
i mean it's like the cleveland indians
are catching heat
the washington redskins are catching
heat yeah the pontiac car is still
floating bring up a pontiac if you can
brother yeah i mean
is cancer culture going to get to that
it should when you think of how many
things are named after native american
stuff it's like you really and i can't
think of them right now
steak oh yeah it's a lot brother let me
ask you this question as far as the
cleveland indians what's worse sounding
to you the cleveland indians or the
cleveland browns cleveland browns sounds
a lot more like a slur to me
oh that's hate these browns oh he's
[ __ ] browns i hate the browns every
year sounds a lot worse than i hate the
cleveland indians just yeah look at
these indians look at these indians
where they look at these browns are
these indias these indias um
yeah i mean look i love a racial slur
honestly and uh who doesn't
if it's set in just
yeah bro even if here's the best if
you're walking down the street somebody
yells it you don't see who yells it
it's [ __ ] great yeah if somebody like
is point blank like ripping me that's
[ __ ] up dude but somebody's using
somebody you know drives by and they
yell it bruh [ __ ] new you know yeah
it's a that that enhances your day oh
kurt metzger has the best slur i've
heard for greeks ever is that my phone i
apologize jesus christ special needs
brother time for your daughter to wake
up
um kurt metzger has the best slur for
greeks that i've ever heard because
there's it's there's not many
and he just uh one time he was doing the
stand-up set it's online somewhere but
he just goes he was dating a greek girl
and her dad didn't approve as greek dads
usually don't of anyone greeks hate
everybody and he just goes can you
believe that dude
a diner monkey from ass [ __ ] island
i was like
that's the best that's the best slur
diner monkey from ass [ __ ] island
doesn't get better than that so that's
what i am i like that yeah man
because we do diners is like the that's
like the greek passport into america and
why is it because of all the dishes and
stuff because y'all guys are like dishes
is a big party house culture huh yeah
maybe that's why i never thought of it
maybe it's because access to dishes
that's the first time i've heard that
theory huh you came up with that in a
split second too
well it's i guess we throw them we throw
them right it's part of the it's like a
tradition yeah so yeah i don't know that
much about greeks man um
is that
we got a healthy history man oh well i
know i've seen a lot of the artwork and
stuff like that yeah now that's
beautiful little penises though a lot of
statues little pieces oh they didn't
really they saved cement huh yeah
yeah
you got around there yeah i don't know
why they did that but all the penises
are really small in the old statues well
do greek girls have big butts i think a
lot of the penis size of the males of a
culture has to do with the size if you
have to reach the vagina of the woman
you know
you're coming up with some theories that
i haven't thought about you so you're
saying you were saying without saying
correct me if i'm wrong yeah you're
saying without saying black dudes got
big dicks because black girls got big
asses
and to be able to reach the vagina they
have to so it kind of evolved that way i
think so i mean it makes sense
yeah i mean when i think about a lot of
times if i think about having sex with a
black girl it's like well i mean all
this certainly depends but it's like
i couldn't do it you got your dick has
to wear lifts yeah to get there yeah
yeah
like you gotta get to do all the dick's
shoulders
yoga yeah my dick's gonna need to be
like one of the ones with the like two
kids in a like top coat
like oh i'm here to let my kid go on the
field trip yeah yeah oh my god and
chinese asian
no butts no butts and also
corresponding correlated yeah
hypothetically hypothetically but we all
know it's true littler penises yeah
holy [ __ ] maybe
because yeah i mean that's just like
about nature like a hummingbird
has to have that beat because it has to
be able to um
this
you know what i'm saying but it's not
right
so i think you might have just lost
confidence in it you might yeah i mean
you might you might have been going
somewhere yeah hummingbird has to have a
beak because it just you know it gets in
a certain type of flowers and it's like
the deep ones was that the moment when
you realize you didn't know that much
about hummingbirds i think it's the
moment i realized i didn't know that
much yeah you had you had enough
knowledge to get you to that point yeah
and then you're like what else did they
do yeah i'm done yeah i'm done with that
okay so you guys started in new york i
just wanna i know a lot of people know
you but i want to make sure that my
audience knows i appreciate that i
forget that sometimes like even though
like i have some knowledge of of someone
or you know i know that they're a great
comedian or um but my audience doesn't
know so you started out in new york
started out new york grew up there i
grew up in brooklyn new york
greek american uh grew up i started
there um long time ago
quit for a while uh had some things
happen and uh you know trauma and things
like that my head's all messed up which
is a constant challenge and then uh i
got back into it and um i started doing
stand-up consistently donald rawlings
was really the guy who got me into
comedy like stand-up got me back in
after i quit and i was doing sketch 2
and i did some viral characters on
youtube early and early in youtube
and uh started touring doing those but
always was a stand-up i started as a
stand-up and i've been doing it you know
on and off because i took some time off
you know of like
i'd say close to 20 years man 15 20
years i've been around i'm like the bull
durham yeah even when i did new faces in
montreal which is like comics that's
like when the industry takes a look at
your whatever i was like i was like the
dude i mean i was in what was i i was in
my late 30s i felt like bull durham yeah
everybody else was these young prospects
and i'm like i was like an old catcher
been around you know yeah you got icy
hot on before
yeah i had like i have little tricks oil
here like the dude from major league the
old reliever
yeah you're like oh the guy after he's
like oh why does this mic have sap on it
yeah like i said that's an old-timer
trick you know
wow so um when you took time off what
did you think because i had a i had a
spot where i think for probably about
seven months i took off i just felt like
i wasn't maybe i didn't know what i was
doing
was there a reason that you took some
time off what was it yeah so i uh i got
shot early on i started doing comedy in
2000
i got shot in 2001 by a gun buy a gun
yeah no way yeah yeah wow and what did
it feel like it burns it's hot
it's just hot think about that yeah it's
hot you don't you know your body takes
care of you like chemicals whatever that
is for the pain and like
your body releases [ __ ] that kind of
bites dmt daddy yeah it's dmt
i guess but then afterwards when all
that adrenaline adrenaline and also
adrenaline when adrenaline dies down
it's just heat it's hot you could
actually see smoke coming out of the
hole like a little bit of smoke yeah
yeah damn
and uh so that was fun though when night
in the hospital i got shot like close to
you know my dick and ass did you really
yeah like right here yeah ooh and you
could see smoke coming out so for a
second yeah you could see a little smoke
coming out when they cut my plastic
pants off of me jogging pants or
whatever you call them like your femur
is [ __ ] vaping in there
yeah that's what it looked like
and um and then you feel the heat and
then a little sting when all the
chemical when all the whatever
adrenaline rushes uh comes down and i
just got lucky it didn't hit an artery
or anything like that but you know the
the that wasn't the the problem was was
the panic attacks that started
afterwards like sort of the ptsd that
i didn't know what it was and so i
started having like these panic attacks
and i it was related to the trauma from
that like just walking around being
scared like oh [ __ ] that happened to me
it could happen any moment and i didn't
know what it was so i just dealt with it
for a while i didn't know what trauma
was or what was going on i would just
get on a train in new york and i would
just start bugging out and like
hyperventilating wow and then not
knowing why is like my subconscious so
i'm going what the [ __ ] is going on and
i just live like that for a while and so
i quit comedy because i i get up on
stage and i'd have these massive panic
attacks
you're making me pain yeah right now it
was weird time and then i i just kind of
quit started doing social work i did 9
11 disaster relief for a while
and uh donald wrongs like i said was the
guy who kind of pulled me in he saw me
once
uh thought i was funny and then he uh he
had a room on the upper east side of new
york city every tuesday wednesday uh
called marion square and i would get up
there once a week and then chappelle
show this about 2005-6 your peloso took
off he took me on the road with him
charlie uh it was bill burr for a little
bit then uh christian finnegan from the
show yeah and uh that was real nice of
him so i always uh i i always owe him
for that i always like
you know it was a real nice thing for
like you know a comic to be like hey
you're funny and then like try to help
me which i did i yeah i'd sell his
posters and i'd do five minutes and it
was nice to also go on the road and see
success because i had never seen anyone
like make it and i knew dino before he
made it and then like i saw his outfit
change yeah and i some go from timbo's
to like
a higher priced
higher priced shoe yeah like the outfit
change that's where you can tell money
and comedy i've seen i've seen a lot of
my friends now you know yeah even tim
dillon's gone from like
bin basket polo yeah to like balanciago
or some italian name i can't even
pronounce wow without sounding like i'm
from new york too much
yeah it's just a it's an outfit change
now did you i'm gonna go through a
little bit of that so yeah with the
trauma stuff did you know that it was
part of um
[Music]
like did you see you felt a lot of
anxiety i'm guessing like uncovered but
were you able to relate immediately that
that it was because of the gunshot thing
no it took me i had to go to therapy
finally i went to therapy i just was
like muscling through it
not knowing like i i it was kind of
emasculating for it to happen be like
why am i so scared i would i would
freeze up i would like i wouldn't be
there was one time i thought i was
having a heart attack and i couldn't
move and my whole body just kind of
froze i couldn't move i guess that's
what they call scared stiff
and uh i told my friend i was with my
friend on the train i was like call
ambulance i'm having a heart attack and
they came and they're like you're fine
like what they took all my vitals and i
was like
i was like because you don't feel fine
so you're going like you must be wrong
you must be wrong i'm dying and i wasn't
and it was just these panic attacks that
would happen and i i really didn't
have a reprieve from them i didn't
really get away from them until i
started going to therapy therapy works
you got issues i recommend therapy yeah
yeah i recommend therapy um and what
were you able so how did they what was
the process kind of of relating
of figuring out that that was it it was
uh sitting with a therapist being she
was a female therapist i was attracted
to her
so did you tell her that i didn't tell
her that which felt like i wasn't being
open in therapy
you know because that must have been a
thing like a mommy issue or something
but because of that i was just more
i don't know i was more vulnerable open
like guys you always a little
standoffish when you sit with a guy
you're like [ __ ] you're a guy like i
don't i gotta i can't be vulnerable
around a guy you always gotta be a guy
but a woman you just kind of you can act
a little more like a woman and talk
about your feelings right so i was able
to something about her
opened me up and i was able to talk
about it and uh
and i got over the fact that i wanted to
sleep with her maybe it's because of the
connection you know we're comics we're
all [ __ ] up we got walls up there's
reasons why we stand on wood planks for
chicken fingers for 10 years to have
strangers give us
uh
you know it's because we didn't get
something else
so there's walls up but she was able to
take those down she was beautiful too
god her legs was the problem if she wore
pants more
but maybe that's what opened me up i was
always distracted with her legs oh yeah
yeah they were just nice oh i noticed
i'll be involved in anything do not hear
a set of high heels in the distance and
i have no control over my ability to
zone out of whatever
[Music]
um
is going on so the the sound of high
heels
yeah and it's not even about sex it's
just the idea
that a woman could be around you know i
think when i was young i didn't get that
care and so it was like the simple idea
that a woman could be coming around to
give me some type of care affection oh
like
it's like there's a part of me that just
cannot help but
go and listen for that listen to that i
read it the wrong way i like i was
reading it like a like a predator
hearing pray like you know oh no like a
coyote hearing like movement in the
brush
no you were yours was more of like a
nurturing thing you needed yeah yeah i
think that's where that kind of yeah
with chicks it for me is that's the
first part of it do you like to suck to
did you were you breast fed
by a small breast
so
you do you like when you get a big one
do you just
oh i
definitely
i have i've overstayed my welcome yeah
on a big tit this is like the second or
third time already in this podcast
you've said something without saying
something and i picked up on it the
first one was but now i know you were
basically saying your mom had small
breasts oh my mom knows it yeah is if
she the one who breastfed was your mom
who breastfed you i i i sometimes
another woman will get in there in
african villages yeah no my sister's
aunts my sister's cousin-in-law brett
they would breastfeed each other's
children the um but i believe that my
mother did it as far as i know right but
yeah small breasts you never shake the
trauma from be
breastfeeding out of a small breast you
never the [ __ ] just the rattle just
trying to rattle a drop of milk out of
something so small it's insane it's
insane that we let a child do it
what's insane when you sit think about
right now a kid
unlike a lowercase a cup i just imagine
you not being able to get find anything
you're trying to grab you just you know
you're just hitting the bag you just you
know and there's just nothing in there
like a wall climber looking for
somewhere to put your fingers and
there's just nothing it's just a flat
wall
it's not it's traumatic it's definitely
exactly what you said it's traumatic
crazy that you remember that too even
though there was no video evidence
well i do believe that when i start to i
can feel the desperation of it and the
why isn't there something there so you
remember the feeling not necessarily the
facts well i think i always have that
feeling right something i'm missing
something something isn't available
right something isn't
complete right so i just take it back to
usually things like that probably and
not specifically breastfeeding but
just the feminine connect me to a you
know connecting to a feminine a feminine
across the board yeah you know but
do you want things to be complete
like
being alive is kind of incomplete we're
only complete when we die and we you
know
god willing we go we go to the party you
know yeah
yeah i just think if your foundation has
a you know if you got all the stair
steps and you can get onto the porch you
know yeah and so i always feel like we
[ __ ] just had a pile of wood right
there
no nails
i like it no plan that analogy was very
like
that was like your background you're
like you saw a porch you went the stairs
i would have gone like elevator push the
button oh wow yeah were you guys pretty
well off growing up we were okay we were
okay yeah i was my friends had less
money my parents were both lawyers oh
wow really yeah but they made like a
hundred thousand dollars which back then
was like a lot of money still a lot
still a lot i guess it's still but back
then i guess it was a lot a lot
yeah yeah a hundred thousand back then
man that was almost as much as you could
have it seemed like i don't even think
it was possible to have more than a
hundred thousand right somebody had a
hundred thousand dollars yeah i don't
you never heard of anyone if someone had
more than a hundred thousand dollars
back then they hit it they did not talk
about it they were yeah they were they
were doing something real illegal yeah
i felt the only way to get more than a
hundred thousand was illegal i felt like
back then
there was like a cap back then it seemed
like it yeah you know um
so we were we were okay we were pretty
well off like i went to private school
oh so they had enough to send me to
private school yeah but back then
private school was like you know 10
grand a year 15 grand a year something
like that it wasn't like now which is
like
it's a lot you got to re you have to
have a lot more than a hundred thousand
dollars to go to private school now
um but all my friends went to public
school so they would just they would oh
that's good yeah they would always steal
money out of my dad's pocket when he
left his pants up on the and do greeks
oh yeah do greeks carry a lot i feel
like greeks carry like a lot of cash on
them always cash apparently white people
are they very paranoid defensive people
yeah
they're uh we were formerly enslaved by
the turks so i think all people
who are like uh you know i think the
irish have it a little because the
english [ __ ] them it is heartbreaking
right like lauren think about it yeah
because then all that trauma gets stuck
in people then it's coming out in crazy
ways you know it's coming out and some
guy [ __ ] you know beating somebody's
face in with a hard hero over here you
know
common crime in the greek community it
never ends
that's when the air damage we were
talking about can happen to a hero too
yeah
um okay so now you've been in new york
for a long time you've done comedy over
the years you got shot you took a break
who shot you do you know i do know who
shot me yeah well i know i don't know
him he's not like i didn't know him
personally but we had to go to trial and
everything he pled not guilty oh yeah so
i had to sit there and
testify and uh
yeah
it was just it was an attempted robbery
because i was with the the friend i was
with was a promoter so he carried a lot
of cash with him so i assume it was an
attempted robbery or carjacking or both
you know and i was just wrong place
wrong time and i made the
i maybe the wrong decision or right i
mean
in that moment you know you're either
like free like i just grabbed his arm
and tried to get it away and fired and i
just
point blank range
i got shot maybe it would have been
worse if he was farther away so the
bullet had a little chance to i don't
know how fast i don't know which
bullet goes faster i'm not i'm not a
ballistics expert like if a bullet picks
up steam or loses yeah does it pick up
steam i guess at a certain point it
would pick up steam right certain
distance there must be an apex
if you're a certain distance away where
it's the fastest where you could do the
most damage i don't know
thank god it was a little fatter then
because it got caught in my butt cheek
and the bullet stayed in there is it
still in there no i took it out a couple
of years later that was a wild moment
when they took it out because
uh they put you under
and
the way i came to
and they had me up in stirrups like i
was at a gynecologist because they the
surgery happened right here so i came to
like this with my legs up and i came to
when i farted
and i farted with the doctor and and the
nurse down there and they were like
laughing because i farted but like i
didn't know where i was and i had to
pass gas
and then they took it out
and it was that's that's all i remember
about that surgery and that put an end
to that trauma
really right when the bullet came out do
you feel like it was just having the
bullet in you still like yeah carrot was
in there it like totally yeah the spirit
of it was in there yeah the spirit of it
was like an invasion like the bullet was
like
you know it was it was my it wasn't
paying rent yeah part of my buy all the
rest of my organs pay rent yeah and
there was this thing and i was just
freeloading damn and i was like i got to
get this freeloader so finally
we evicted that we evicted that bad
tenant that was in my leg and uh that's
unbelievable man i didn't even know that
that happened to you yeah
yeah i've spoken about a few times
um i never really joked about it or made
jokes out of it uh because it was i it
wasn't funny to me it was like that
would make me sad and i didn't know what
was funny about it now i feel a lot
better about it it happened a long time
ago you know i feel like i'm solidly a
man now you know as a comic i don't
think i became solidly a man until like
two years ago really yeah we're all yeah
don't you feel like are you growing you
have grandkids no i don't have anything
like that i don't know i don't even have
original children yeah
do you have uh
fake ones or imaginary replica ones no i
don't have any wife or nothing like that
yet i plan on getting it though you do i
know i learned a lot about it yeah
you're special yeah i watched let me see
34 minutes of your special that's about
that's right that's probably more than
what the algorithm is telling me that
people watch so it was cool farther than
most people yeah it's really really cool
um
what's the name of it i i don't oh wait
i do know what it is it's called um
something mom mom love mom love sorry
mom love no that
um anything in the area of mom it's like
pronouncing my name i'll respond to
yannis giannis giannis yeah and i could
i mean i could have looked at the
wikipedia page before i just forgot what
it was named i'm not trying to say that
i don't care no i know okay cool yeah
yeah totally um
yes you got the new special this is on
youtube it's on youtube yeah it's on
youtube it's cool man you shot over
there madison which was nice really cool
spot yeah and when i shot it i just
decided to shoot it that night i had no
plans to say i did my album a couple
years ago that's comedy on stage too
which is like it's a great club it's
just
run well and the audience is always
great and you know who runs it greeks
yeah great crazy two greek young ladies
and their greek father who's
really killed it i mean he came to this
country like with like five bucks now he
owns he owns like the whole state street
they should rename it to like state
docky street it's like greek yeah greeks
conquered we came and we like
like alexander he came and he just took
over all the restaurants there alexander
the greek right alexander the greek yeah
he was alexander the great but yeah he
was great
macedonians will say he's macedonian
greeks will say he's greek they fight
about it and it's like guys who cares
it's like one of those
inter-fighting things where you're like
dude like it's like between like serbs
and croats you're like guys i can't
[ __ ] tell the difference like the ira
the northern irish and southern they're
[ __ ] fighting the ukrainians and
russians if i put a ukrainian russian
here right now do you think
one out of ten people from any country
will be able to tell me what the
difference is when they start [ __ ]
talking between ukraine and russia what
are they fighting over aren't they the
same kind of like northern i think a
syllable probably i think there's a
couple syllables still on the board for
or like a vowel maybe probably if
they're fighting over anything it's
probably a vowel over there because if
you hear those people talk you don't
there's zero vowels involved
yeah oh stop all these and l's now
yeah then the norwegians and swedes they
have their hate for each other like
people just hate each humans like to
hate yeah we'll hate whatever's closest
it's just well i think what do you what
do you think that is i think part of it
is because you just want to there's some
need to feel what
why do people want to hate
i think part of it is uh it gives you a
feeling of feeling okay
if i can think this is worse yeah if i
can think that that person is
is not as good
it's easier i think it's scary like what
i think eye contact is scary i think
making strong eye contact if you keep
making it for a long time i think two
people are either going to fight or [ __ ]
okay like okay you have to look away at
some point whereas it gets too powerful
or like fall in love like eye contact
it's a good point ever thought about
that there was like a spectrum of eye
contact yeah you got at some point you
got to like look away you're like are we
going to [ __ ] you know like i can't i
mean or somebody's going to see
something in you that you don't want
them to see or that it's going to be
you're going to be too
you're too insecure you know you don't
want the person to know you're lying or
whatever it is or you're hiding
something so i think that's the thing
that is a barrier always with people and
i [ __ ] you i don't want you yeah i'm
hiding something i'm not comfortable
with who i am so
it just turns into like hey yeah it's
got to be that
right
i would think man i mean it's
interesting if you're looking for that
extra confidence when it's time for sex
well
jump in the wagon baby
jump in the dang confidence wagon
and floor it
and let me tell you about bluechew.com
bluechu
uh is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable form
chewable
form and at a fraction of the cost
that's right
blue chew is an online prescription
service no doctor visits no awkward
conversations
no waiting in line at the pharmacy it
ships right to your door in a discreet
package
if you don't like swallowing pills
that's okay
blue chews sildenafle in tada laffel
tablets are
chewable
that's right blue chews tablets are made
in the usa
america
on this wiener and they prepare and ship
direct so it's cheaper than a pharmacy
and here's a special deal for you you
know it try bluetooth free
when you use our promo code theo at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's blueechew.com
promo code theo to receive your first
month for free you know life can be
overwhelming and many people are burned
out without knowing it i've been one of
those i still am a lot of times honestly
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless or trapped detachment
fatigue
and more
we often associate burnout with work but
that's not the only cause of it
you know any of our roles in life can
lead us to feeling burned out
and better help online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to that's nice
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours
tpw listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
theo
that's better h e l p dot com slash
t-h-e-o
i've needed help and i've gotten it
through better help and you can as well
that's why i almost became a quaker
you didn't almost became a quaker i
almost chose to become a quaker were you
gonna marry into it or no no i was just
gonna show up one day and be like i'm
down with what you guys are doing what's
the deal do i gotta do paperwork or do i
you got to dunk me in water i want to do
what you're doing
because the way they get married
i went to a quaker school for a little
while brooklyn friends right because
like these quaker schools and their
thing is real beautiful man it's about
silence really so like every day they
have a silent meeting and everyone just
sits in silence and nobody speaks unless
they're moved to speak and then the
weddings
the the
bride and groom to be or whatever
they're called i don't know what the
quakers call them yeah you know whatever
they may have some like allegories from
quakers or they call the weddings what
i don't know but at a quaker wedding
yeah i don't know the way they get
married is a guy and the guy and girl
who are getting married yeah just and
all their friends gather around the guy
and girl just sit for about an hour and
stare at each other and everyone sits in
silence and then after about an hour or
so they're just married and nobody
speaks unless god moves them to speak
and that's it and i just thought that
was so beautiful because if you're
sitting with the person you're going to
spend the rest of your life with and
you're sitting there for an hour you're
probably having every fear every hope
every insecurity
everything transpire in your head yeah
and you're just like
it must be a real
like just
roller coaster of emotions and if you
feel good about it after that hour you
know you're probably doing the right
thing but if you start feeling some
bad feelings you probably know you're
gonna have to
cheat wow yeah i guess at that point you
really all you're left with sitting
there after an hour probably is some
pure ass honesty probably that's right
yeah i you said it a lot
better than i that's what i was trying
to say yeah and then i guess some of
your friends do they speak up in those
instances or not if god moves them
supposedly but can you bring that up
here what do we have like a quaker
wedding sit in or is it like a um
[Music]
yeah i wonder what they would call it
i don't know yeah maybe they just call
it a quaker wedding
yeah that's a good question man what do
they call it
do quakers make
often referred to as the silent ceremony
quaker weddings
differ
from the traditional protestant ceremony
in four significant ways there is no
efficient
no giving away the bride
a wedding certificate is signed and
there's a long period of silent open
worship after which those attending may
speak on the
couple's behalf
and you know the quakers were against
slavery too early on they're pretty
they're pretty like clean dude i like
that religion man it's just kind of
quiet and like
no mantra no dogma
bring up some images of these folks huh
do you mind so we know who we're
actually considering here
well they they look like the dude on the
quake quaker oats box they all look like
that oh god really still yeah they still
kind of roll like that hmm get some vans
or something at least
they got it gotta they gotta change a
little bit throw on some damn quick
silver or something you know yeah some a
little more weather appropriate at least
yeah orthodox jews the same thing they
wear the same wool
like black suits even like in the middle
of july oh dude i was at this halfway
hour like not a halfway house but like a
recovery house or whatever and this
orthodox jewish dude had to roll in
right and this and it's just like you
know different guys staying in there and
stuff
and
this guy rolls up dude he was dressed
like biggie smalls right it was last
summer
bro it was this was in arizona it was
104 degrees this dude rolls out just
like bakey smalls and had a grill that
he would cook his food on in his room at
night really just grilling this like
kind of shady fish kind of like this
[ __ ] you know
i don't know what type of fish it was
but i i it just it was unveiled the dude
is pouring sweat his hands were all
sweaty every time you shook his hand it
felt like you were like babysitting one
of those uh
like one of those oil spill animals you
know it was just
disgusting bro
i'm like oh my i was like if you were
like
get this will kill you you can't this
can't be like a
heavenly choice or whatever you'll die
in this yeah they
i guess when their
mantra or whatever their dogma says this
is how you dress wow it doesn't change
there's no update yeah like there's no
there's got to be jesus like whoever
their jesus is has to come back and be
like
dude thank god i came back to tell you
this because i can't watch you guys
suffer anymore yeah you don't have to
you can take a couple layers off when
it's hot oh we need tank tops yeah fam i
like to call this shady fish was it a
shady fish because you just couldn't
identify it i mean anybody that's
grilling room a fish in their room on a
little grill like that at night trying
to and he was trying to secretly do it i
think because one of the rules was you
couldn't cook in your room because a lot
of people are drug users in there ah so
one dude's cooking a fish one dude's
cooking up a batch of whatever you know
some fireball for his arm you know so
it's like the guys will cheat they're
like oh he cooking i'm a cook so it
wasn't the fish that was shady it was
the whole
situation what was going on though he
was more shady it was breaking the rules
oh okay so the fish was just a fish yeah
all right cause i was trying to picture
of shady fish being like and he kept
wanting like gum or something from me i
think he couldn't have gum so he was
like break it was like i had some kind
of candy or something he kept one oh it
was nerd ropes so this dude [ __ ] kept
every time i get my nerd ropes open
he could hear the bag from the distance
bro from across the desert dude like we
with high heels and you oh
yeah he'd come around
and then watch him just nibble on this
nerd rope this dude oh
goimel or someone's name i don't know
that dude was oh have you ever uh like
this is what i like in my background in
new york there's a lot of like irish
catholic girls like catholic puerto
ricans catholic was a big religion it's
very repressive
sexually
i almost felt like when you hooked up
with one of those girls
that the repression was worth it for
their
energy they were so
happy like you know like a religious
dude with nerd rope or whatever little
thing he can get that's not allowed it's
almost worth it like sexually it's
almost worth it for us all to be
repressed to give it a little something
extra oh i i i think that's what some of
the value in the having the repression
in religion for sex is yeah it's like to
keep some energy in it to keep some fuel
in the tank yeah and yeah there's
definitely been a gal when she gets a
hold of your
nerd rope if you will even which is
still i don't even think about that a
great term for a wiener it is a really
good way uh
yeah they're definitely more keyed up
about it
like there's some
girls that'll damn floss their teeth
with it you know if you let them because
it's just like so forbidden yeah it's
just that forbidden you know it's a real
dessert yeah but if you just all day
you're just over there with your legs
open at the bakery then you definitely
becomes tried it becomes there's no
value in it yeah
it's kind of a lot of our society we
burnt out a lot of the value of things i
think that's where we're at right now me
too we're almost like freedom's gotten
too free well pornographies burn down
like any like a lot of sexual energy so
i think you have a lot of marriages that
probably are
i wonder if you could calculate how much
pornography has killed marriages it's
probably killed a lot
not even marriage is just sex drive and
like imagination and
you know like uh it's bad pornography is
bad and like it's bad because there's no
smells in it there's no people's
feelings in it
you're just it's something got to be
very unnatural about just staring at his
modern screen
moving pictures of something else that
you can't smell it's just like visual
and you're it that's got to be something
bad for your brain there
oh dude i remember biking across town
i'd bike over there i knew a buddy had a
couple titty mags over there his daddy
hit him right
and uh
we'd bike kept him in the bathroom and
i'd bike over to his house it was like
seven miles from my house dude it took
me half of a sunday to get over there
and i'd bike over there and then just
use their [ __ ] all afternoon and i'd
just be in there playing with myself
they must have thought i was insane dude
i would come over there on the weekends
and be all sweaty
go in there just use a can for a while
touch myself and then drink a bunch of
water take a nap and then bike back home
hydrate you have to hide because you
thank god you must you you that means
you had a vigorous masturbation
it was everything you had was in there
yeah yeah you really back then you
really yeah it was unionized yeah i was
saying the [ __ ] we got now
you're lucky if you get ladder 14 out
there yeah yeah
the um the mags because i i'm from that
generation too
so i used to put them out like that i
used to put them out yeah and then like
we would we would share them one person
would be one friend would be done with
them pass them off to you and there'd be
a circle i would put the mags out like
that like four of them and make my own
moving picture just by looking at all oh
just real fast yeah just real fast i
would go like counter clockwise too and
i would just try you know yeah yeah so i
was kind of ahead of the game when it
like you know oh yeah yeah a little bit
i was making it yeah yeah i did my i
used my imagination in some way to make
this situation a little more valuable
yeah because it's hard to just look at a
calvin klein ad and just
it's tough kate moss only lasts you know
it's just like
you know you need movement you need
something else yeah i need more yeah i'm
a guy who needs a little more you know i
need love i need a woman you know to be
distant i need her to be adopted like
that's what i need yeah in order for me
to feel something i need her to have
some real big issue that i'm trying to
solve that'll never be solved that i can
chase hmm like um adoption's a good one
adopted women are
like a nicholas cage movie almost that's
a whole you can never feel the rejection
from the mother
so is amber heard adopted i would have
like if she i would not be surprised she
was adopted she has that vibe to her
she adopted
let's look it up i'm taking i'm taking a
guess
because adopted adopted people just that
the rejection from the mom is just
on that level you know a lot of us don't
get the nurture and all that but like
to just say he i don't want it that's
something you can't fill
but so there's something alluring to it
amber heard
i can't see those are do you find her
attractive amber
her was born
she not adopted
yeah i don't think she was adopted
she's a younger sister named whitney
um
do i i actually a buddy of mine had a
birthday and she and i both like spoke
at his birthday or whatever did like a
little
i don't think it's like a eulogy i don't
know what it is but like a thing you
know
and uh
so that was kind of interesting just one
time getting like
um
[Music]
met her just briefly i don't know i i i
don't to me she's not that she's not my
type i don't think but what's your type
mmm
just probably different than her maybe
okay
not blonde not blondier girls don't like
me really no they've never
i'm getting a lot of blonde you know
what do you get man what do you have i
know you got one you especially have
some great jokes about weddings man i
was howling thank you dude i appreciate
that i was howling dude thank you uh my
my wife she's she's greek oh wow do you
have to marry a greek i didn't have to
and i did which is weird because my
parents didn't care about that at all
and i did it which makes me
figure why did i do that but i love her
i love my wife there you go good that's
a good thing and i didn't marry her
because she was greek i just married her
because the vibe was nice
i got i i when i met her i think i was
at a point in my life where i'd made so
many mistakes
i don't regret any of them because they
were all fun they were just meant to end
some of the fun of [ __ ] is just meant to
end
and so like you can't ever you just look
back and go like oh that was fun but it
was meant to end
you know dude that's such an interesting
statement man yeah i think so because i
think nobody ever hears that statement
yeah and so a lot of us get stuck in
this space oh the f has to keep going or
there's
but yeah some of the fun is meant to end
wow that's also what makes it fun that's
what makes it so fun
you know this uh this is powerful dawg
yeah i mean it's like damn steve austin
that's powerful like steve austin yeah i
mean everything has a balance here
it's a finite universe you run all the
way in this direction you're gonna come
out on the other side like miss pac-man
like this is not an infinite universe so
it's always seeking balance and like the
fun or something is
you know the more you're going to pay
for it later you're either going to pay
in life people think they're not going
to pay but that's just because you
didn't have to pay up top sometimes you
walk into a restaurant you know and you
order first get the food but the checks
coming yeah even though you ate you
think you ate and you're gonna now you
or you're gonna be washing dishes yeah
but you're gonna pay there's always a
cost it's just either you pay up front
or you pay later bam so
yeah if it's that fun it's like the
check's coming
were you giving did you have were you
did you think you wouldn't get married
yeah i wasn't i didn't think i was
getting married i'd have kids all that
stuff frightened me because of issues
and stuff uh you know uh parents were
divorced parents had really had
animosity towards each other and uh my
mother was like a little cold
you know she wasn't very nurturing oh
yeah yeah so that makes it a little
intimacy a weird thing did you ever go
to any of the recovery meetings or are
getting the programs they're like no no
no no no i do go to therapy though
therapy helps therapy helps if me a lot
my therapist i love i think he's great
you know i just connect with him and
it works for me it's a man now you got a
man now i'm a man i think i'm a man
enough now to be able to open up to a
man wow back then it was just like i had
to be a woman because i felt too
vulnerable now i could cry in front of a
man dude i could [ __ ] cry in front of
a man
i mean i don't cry a lot i haven't cried
a lot but i can [ __ ] yeah i can [ __ ]
do it [ __ ] you if it came to it like
you know we got in like a serious
[ __ ] convo i wouldn't hide it oh i'll
cry against anybody yeah i'll [ __ ]
cry i'll put on [ __ ] shoulder pads
any helmet cry
cry the [ __ ] out of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] two teddies dog i'll get two
touchdowns and [ __ ] cry
[Laughter]
you're comfortable with who you are then
that means yeah oh dude yeah i'll cry
for 400 yards dog yeah and six
touchdowns dude i'm not afraid to do it
you got like a you got like a i love
your i said it before i think i might
have said it on someone's podcast but
like you got a rhythm to you it's like
listening to comedy jazz oh thanks man
and then you imagine you're painting
these pictures and you're like wow
you're just like there you go wow the
[ __ ] is a shady fish there you start to
see it you start to see the the fish act
in shade you see the dude like you paint
a picture with your comedy it's and it's
jazz it's very very very rhythmic
thanks man
like is that maybe that's like louisiana
i mean it's that influence of kind of
just like
yeah rhythm yeah
yeah i don't know when i'm feeling good
everything feels pretty good i always
feel rude around a southerner
i feel rude i feel like my rhythm is
rude
like i'm you know what i mean like
because i'm good friends with nate like
me and nate came up together nate bar
gatsby oh yeah yeah he's feeling rude
around like he's and he always kind of
was like like always telling his body
language is always telling me chill like
chill right like what are you and i'm
like i'm just living man and he's like
yeah but it's it you know that's living
at a high level yeah a high octane a
level that's like not where i want to be
and i'm like i'm sorry i'm taking you
know
yeah nate has a real past he's real he
has a real not passiveness but just like
a pacifisticity to him yeah he's real
real
home he seems organized yeah like he'd
be a good general i think
like a quiet general yeah maybe maybe
things would have been different if he
was
back then maybe the south
he they lost maybe they were a little
too laid back
yeah you guys lost that well i think we
had good generals but i think we just
didn't have uh
well i don't know if we let enough of
the
favorite if they would have used more if
they would have had more slaves fight as
well
yeah but the cause wasn't right yeah
yeah i think the whole thing was kind of
discombobulated
it was definitely discombobulated yeah
that was
a good word to say
do you think that they we could ever get
back to another civil war
yeah unfortunately yeah
i do
yeah but it wouldn't be the same states
against each other this time
um
yeah that's an interesting thing to
think because it's different it's not
like yeah
what would it be or to be over it may
not even be geographical it may be more
uh
city versus country where like the
countries just
had enough dude i i feel like it could
be religious almost too even yeah where
people want
more religious beliefs or religious
based beliefs i don't know i think maybe
i think maybe a religious dictator may
be the only thing that could pull us
back together like joel osteen if he got
in power at
talk i mean he's got his i was just
thinking i didn't even he's got a mullet
kind of right he's got kind of that soft
boy mo like somebody that plays second
base that kind of gets a mullet yeah you
know yeah he's not but still
no he's still trying to be handsome yeah
you got to grow it past handsome yeah
you gotta have full balls once you grow
your mullet past handsome dude that's
when you know you that's that's when it
knows you want it
so it's comfortable you you're
comfortable with it it's a full
commitment you're married at that point
you're in a relationship with your hair
yeah once you sat there for an hour
together he's just dating his hair right
now yeah he's still it's still like yeah
yeah it's still in the dating phase yeah
what would a civil war be about
um it would probably be about abortion
uh abortion would be one of them
um
bathrooms people really upset about
bathrooms
like yo man some one group's like yo we
got enough bathrooms and another side's
like yo we need more
bathrooms
yeah and it's ironic because
construction workers
most of the time believe in less
bathrooms but it would be good for their
business to build more
you know i mean that's a great point
even think about that yeah and i always
wanted to i always wanted to know if
there should be like
i don't
like
should there be gay and straight
bathrooms gay and straight as well
well because if i'm a gay dude yeah and
i get to roll into a place where other
dudes has their penises out yeah
it's like a fat dude walking into a
barbecue this is great
but that's okay right well i i'm not
saying there's anything wrong with it no
but i understand what you're saying
questioning like you know
is that or if there's a
should there be hey i'm a pedophile do
can i just go pee by myself somewhere to
keep me on whatever path i'm you know to
keep me away from
you know what i'm saying like how often
do you separate it yeah i know exactly
these are really difficult problems to
solve because what if you know you're a
pediaphile right you know it pediatric
and you don't want to go in there yeah
you don't want to go in there because
it's just pediatrics are very hydrating
better very hydrated pedophile because
you mix pedialyte
and uh and pedophile
let me just turn that's that's me on
youtube
yeah just turn it off yeah not a crazy
idea
yeah because i don't know because it's
just like we keep separating everything
we keep separating everything you know
but we you kind of have to that's the
problem like to govern this whole thing
that's the problem with freedom it's
like the oxymoronic thing about freedom
is
uh you know
i need to be okay with you doing
something different and and you need to
be okay with me doing something
different but by virtue of the fact that
we're okay with us doing something
different because we're free we don't
want to hang out with each other so we
separate and then somehow you got to be
like world it's got to be like a detan
like hey man you're going to that club
i'm going to this club you believe in
that i believe in that obviously we're
not going to hang out because we believe
different things but that's going to
create separation and eventually cause
a problem yeah that threatens freedom so
it's kind of like this built-in
oxymoronic tenant to [ __ ] what
freedom is it's like built to fail
and that's why authoritarians always
come in and just make everything the
same
you know
and then you're like [ __ ] that was
inevitable and then that gets stale
because you know
you need you need jewish people to
complain in order for things to get
better
yeah you know like if hitler got what he
wanted
they wouldn't nothing would get better
because there's nobody around to be like
ah this place is a little too small it's
a little too hot we need to change this
the food's a little cold
and then nobody knows what's good or not
but then that never ends though yeah you
got to curtail it back i think at some
point you got to christian it back a
little christian because then it's like
if you get so far down that this is
wrong this is then you're just at the
point where it's like the freedom thing
it's like when is this ever right it's
like two negative two negative two
negative right well it's like we're
never
there's always going to be a problem
right right like at some point you can't
always have a problem right at some
point things have got to be like this is
good enough right because then that's
that that fosters greed because you're
like it's not uh this is bad that's bad
maybe this will fix it this will fix it
there's a problem every way you lose
there's a problem we look at everything
it's tough the only way to have be okay
is for us to just [ __ ] die
do you think i've thought about this
sometimes like do you think that humans
are supposed to be here
when you look at the rest of nature it's
really interesting it's like
you know it's really
fascinating to me at this point in my
life
i believe
that
we're our perspective
is as involved in what reality is
as reality is
in and of itself huh you know what i
mean like me and you could be going
through the same
town right
and like let's say i'm hungry like what
walking through it or driving
well we're strolling okay we're
strolling or does that even matter it
doesn't even matter but i like the
visual of it we're walking hanging out
we're talking all right it's a real
mellow talk we're chilling
your mouth's moving a little bit because
it's a little breeze oh yes yeah my hair
looks stupid because my mother-in-law
cut it yeah and i got to figure out a
way to get out of that but that keeps
happening well you guys live with her
well you know i told her once i got
another haircut and she like made some
like passive aggressive comments and now
i'm like
i'm locked into this haircut dude when i
was young this lady missed bobby's to
cut my hair right and she wasn't even i
don't know haircut or not but she had a
stroke one time and i didn't know what
had happened i didn't know if she was
doing something whatever i just met her
and so i [ __ ] sat in this room bro in
the haircutting chair while she laid on
the floor for like six minutes dude i
had no idea what was going on what was
did you ever find out or huh yeah her
daughter came in the room and was like
oh my god they're having a stroke and
they call the ambulance
but it was crazy man i just remember
i didn't know i didn't know if she had
taken a nap or if she was just so old or
something you know that cause any trauma
for you while you're getting a haircut
are you like do you keep asking are you
okay
i i actually ended up cutting my own
hair at some point in my life for like
probably 17 15 17 years yeah but um so
we're walking in the place okay you're
hungry
i'll say you're hungry i want to [ __ ]
all right right so since we're walking
we're inhabiting the same reality but
you're you're driven by a desire to eat
i'm driven by a desire to [ __ ] so you're
going to notice all the food places i'm
going to notice all the [ __ ] okay so
our realities are different so
our desires and our perceptions i think
create what reality is as much as what
it actually is we're walking through the
same place right but we're noticing
different things so the reality is
different for both of us even though
there's this blank slate of what it is
so
it's sort of that thing does a does a
does a tree make a sound in the forest
if nobody's there to hear it um yes and
no
because
you need the
faculty of sound to be able to hear it
so without humans at all
um
it doesn't make a sound
but the only way
the reason why sound is a phenomenon is
because we have ears so we wouldn't even
be asking a question if there was no
people here
so you need both for even the question
to be asked so we're part of this we're
like look you built this whole [ __ ] this
is your imagination like this is like
this is just uh this is just a
manifestation of ideas
this is part of reality now but this was
in you you're like i like this picture
here i want that thing there i want
smart waters for my guests this there's
this is all this is theo like manifested
so like you've
this is reality right but this is you've
made it and this is like you've you've
built it you built reality
you know reality wasn't here without you
it's like
you know so it's it's a little bit of a
symbiotic relationship happening at the
same time
so we kind of like build reality while
we're going like a dark tunnel with
nothing but do you think that we've
sometimes i wonder if years from now
we'll look back and be like holy [ __ ] we
went down a crazy uncomfortable
path of the reality we built you know
and like will we look back and like oh
man that whole path they took was wrong
and this is the correct way to go like
i i just feel like sometimes we've
gotten so far from like nature and
things that really like intrinsically
like make us feel good maybe yeah that
we're so far from those receptors even
that it's getting like kind of not dour
cause life is you know there's a lot of
great moments but overall is it
is
and i want it could just be american
society doing well you know i don't know
comfort corrupts eventually it feels
like that a little bit it does maybe
you're right maybe like we would feel
more fulfilled if we were still hunting
and
women still had hair on their vaginas
and stuff like that there was a little
more unpleasant trees we were used to
because when you make things pleasant
pleasant pleasant then you want more
pleasant more pleasant you're like yeah
oh there's no hair to choke on when i'm
meeting her [ __ ] but now i want her
[ __ ] tastes like honeydew and you just
keep going and you keep going yeah
till like you actually start putting
syrup in there yeah yeah which is where
we're at which is where we're at like if
there's no if it doesn't taste like
syrup then we're a little dissatisfied
yeah i mean people are selling freaking
you know uh condiments and stuff like
that for the body in the crotch
um
[Music]
yeah what else man we had some good news
topics that came up what have what's
happening in the news guys
let me see what do we have here
is that you as abraham lincoln
i guess it is yeah
someone made that that's really a nice
thing somebody drew with all the
different faces on it
that's very cool all the podcasts and
before everything fell apart yeah
because it used to be a real
scene right and now it's like yeah it
still is it's just like more individual
scenes yeah you know yeah do you feel
that because you guys were doing what
you guys did first you guys had history
history hyenas right yeah me and chris
and what happened was there a reason you
guys uh took it off you just run its
course yeah it kind of ran its course he
wanted to do different things and uh you
know uh i wanted to do different things
and uh you know we ended it kind of on a
high note i guess like you know
um i know there's a lot of speculation
about it and all this but you know it
was there yeah there's a lot of
speculation but in retrospect when you
look back you're like yeah i'm kind of
we're
probably both glad it ended when it did
and that fans should be happy it ended
when it did you know it got a real cult
following people were really into it me
and chris had a real rhythm that we
built and uh it was this two-man comedy
which i love man it's like i love that i
love that i just love feeling you know
it's like me and you would be real good
friends because it's not totally smooth
but there's moments with smooth but if
we spend a lot of time together it would
get really smooth oh wow but it's real i
mean the bumpy moments are kind of real
right that's what that's how i kind of
like like my wife because i usually i
would like if i was seduced by a girl
i'd fall in love with her and then it
would turn [ __ ] and i'm like that's not
the right way to go
and then the people who i want to be
around it's always a little there's work
because anything that's real takes work
yeah so like my wife i didn't have a
great time the first time she bored the
hell out of me i hope she doesn't watch
his podcast really yeah she bored the
hell out of me she just sat there
[ __ ] silent and i remember my friend
who unfortunately is going through a
rough time right now
but he told me i was complaining about i
was like she doesn't talk she doesn't
say anything he's been married for a
long time and he was gone he was going
he was going like that so you're
complaining about that
and then that changed my perspective
which changed my reality i was like oh
[ __ ] maybe that is a good thing long
term that she's kind of chill
comfortable in her own skin doesn't need
to talk all the time because people need
to talk all the time are usually covered
up for the fact that they're they feel
insecure they're bored and i changed my
whole [ __ ] outlook on it wow and then
you end up marrying her and i ended up
marrying her so it's like i love i love
the two man i love like i had a
character and i had a my friend who
passed away angelo we did this live show
and this we did this two-man comedy man
like angela bowers now uh angelo uh
lazada new york comic and uh he passed
away and um it was just there's
something magical about when you're
connecting with someone on a comedic
vibe and
the two you don't know where it's going
yeah you create something bigger than
yourself anytime you're creating
something bigger than yourself
is a beautiful thing i think a lot of
times people get depressed or anxious
because they're thinking about
themselves too much because we're boring
the thing is we may think we're great
but we're all just kind of like shitty
humans walking around [ __ ] and
pissing and having itchy balls and like
we're dying slowly with air air
hardenings happening to us isn't that
wild that oxygen the same thing that
keeps us alive is also slowly killing us
that's what happens really just like a
fruit damn fruit the air gives the fruit
life but if you if you leave it too long
the air actually kills the fruit it rots
it that's air exposure overexposure damn
it's like aaron brockovich kind of it's
exactly like aaron brockovich [ __ ] and
um so i love that two-man thing and
that's what me and chris had and um
and maybe it just kind of reached its
thing where it was like we did it you
know and like when you look back you're
kind of like that comedy exists for the
three years and then he's doing great
stuff i'm doing something different and
was it scary to change that would be the
part that's scary for me the scary part
to change to think like okay something
else is going to come along that's going
to fill this space
or i'm going to this is going to affect
my creativity or it's going to affect my
livelihood even like my ticket sales or
my people to be able to hear me did
those kind of things come into your head
because that's that comes into my head
because i do another podcast you know i
think about well if i didn't do this or
or if i didn't do this or you know now
we're all our own businesses so much
that it's like if i let go of one little
segment of my business is that going to
mess everything up it gets scary yeah i
used to worry a lot more with that i
didn't worry at all and even thinking
about it when you were asking it is like
i don't i get i guess that means i
matured a little bit because it's like
maybe you believe in yourself a little
more or you just trust something's gonna
happen you believe in your talents and
also taking
me accepting my own mortality which was
something that always scared me yeah uh
helps because it takes the pressure off
everything it's like if it's good or
it's not it doesn't matter like because
it's ephemeral it's going away anyway so
might as well try to connect to people
might as well try to have a good time
whether there's money involved or not as
long as i'm having a good time the
experience is the same like if me and he
you were sitting here
this is a huge podcast right
um if it was a small podcast what would
be the difference in the feeling that me
and you were having there'd be no
difference yeah right it'd be no
difference between like what we're
trying to do here trying to get to know
each other which is a you know a
challenge for like we're just meeting
each other too and if it's filmed
because why not monetize that in this
era
and
it's like sometimes my wife talks i'm
like don't speak unless you [ __ ] we
got cameras wrong um
the other day i invited a friend
that i don't know but like kind of a
buddy out for lunch and i was like [ __ ]
it feels insane inviting somebody else
but not a podcast
because it gets so busy but go on i
interrupted it yeah no but i was just
saying it it's uh that takes the
pressure off for me a lot that takes the
pressure off when i think about that i
put things into perspective and go like
when you're talking about do i get
scared like scared about like oh it's
gonna hurt my ticket sales or my
livelihood that fear always creeps in
but then i realized like
even if it does
you know
i'm dying anyway or even if it doesn't
and i get money i'm still dying anyway
so hopefully i'm having a good time damn
and the one thing i did the silver
lining from having that moment when i
got shot and that i can share and it is
an experience that not a lot of people
have that i did have yeah where you
think you're gonna die in that moment
you think it's over and i did not like
the way i felt because you have this
moment it's like a dream
where you
it's hard to explain like you know like
a dream it's like how did that happen in
two seconds how did i how did that whole
story happen and then scientists are
saying like it only happens in a second
your brain somehow does that thing where
you get like this recap where you look
at yourself you have this feeling about
who you are what you've done everything
and uh i was like i didn't like it and
so thankfully i was able to not die then
but i also burned with this knowledge of
like [ __ ] i don't want to feel that
again so like when i have that moment
when i'm dying i want to be chill i want
to be able to be like i like who i am i
like what i did i liked the way i lived
i was true to whatever it is i want to
do and who i am and i tried at least or
to be brave or to be me or whatever it
is was it it felt important in that
moment and like uh wow so i guess that's
the silver lining of that moment it
sucked other than that and like knowing
like oh [ __ ] that's what you live for
you live for that moment you want that
moment to be peaceful you want that
moment because that moment is coming
there's no way to avoid it for any of us
so all this other [ __ ] comes and goes
ups and downs but that [ __ ] is a
certainty and you have that moment of
awareness
that's interesting are you able to
recreate that moment in any other way in
your life that you've noticed since then
or the moment where are there times
you're like oh this is a little bit of a
recreation of that no wow no we could no
there's so much going on
it's so weird that [ __ ] moment man
it's a weird moment [ __ ] where were you
laying down no i was in the car you were
sitting in the car sitting dealing with
him while it was happening and also
that's why i'm saying it's so weird was
also like having all these thoughts you
know and like feelings about people i
love bad things i've done and you're
bleeding i'm bleeding it's all happening
it happens in a second the sound i can't
remember the sequence of it it's just
kind of happening and you're in the
moment
and uh you're in two places i'm in the
moment reacting doing the things i was
doing with him like we were tussling
and uh i was also like someplace else in
this [ __ ] like last moment place
where you're something in you know is
like oh [ __ ] this is it because i didn't
think i was living i mean i'm in a car
i know i'm shot
it feels ominous you know i don't know i
just you my mind just went i'm dying
this is it it's over the whole thing's
over you're in this effect
we you can cognitively know you can
cognitively say to yourself life is
finite but you can't really feel it no
you can't feel it unless you're in it
and then you're like oh [ __ ] and it's
all like the the reality of it being so
ephemeral and all going away is just
like it's freaky man it's like uh just
now when i was talking about i was like
oh that's free it's a you feel like yeah
when you get that feeling sometimes like
this is all gonna disappear one day it's
[ __ ] like just now i felt translucent
i felt invisible just even was talking
about i felt like wow blurry it's like
oh [ __ ] this is all blurry
you know in its essence it's like really
like an abstract painting there's
nothing defined and we're on the way
it's weird and so
i don't know that was a good that was a
silver lining at that moment damn
but it also takes the pressure off it's
scary but it takes a pressure off going
like oh wait you know
yeah if you're having fun
what's the difference yeah because
sometimes i'm like am i how much fun
what am i doing how much pressure am i
putting on myself you know i think about
those things all the time am i working
you know just like
it's hard sometimes to um do you have
any like hobbies you like to do outside
like something else where you're not
thinking about yeah i like doing jiu
jitsu and i like doing um
what else do i like doing playing wordle
playing scrabble on my phone
um how do you feel when you're doing
those things you probably feel no
anxiety when you're doing those things
pretty chill yeah yeah that's why i like
talking to my
brother um
those are all chill [ __ ] dessert
dammit dessert's a great moment
that's a real good moment yeah [ __ ] that
brings a lot of good feelings i had a
couple last night boy had too many i
like going to different meetings and
[ __ ] uh
what um
let's pull that news story that came
back up let's get it one more time i'm
curious as to what happened with the
wedding and stuff like
where you said did you have dating
issues where was just some of your stuff
there because i have a ton of that [ __ ]
man yeah well the merit the wedding
material you talking about oh the
wedding material but no just like you
had said like you know you didn't think
you were going to get married because i
worry about that sometimes i was scared
man like when it came when it comes to
commitment for me it's real hard it's
real hard and i had the same thing i i
give a lot of credit to my buddy paul
verzi who's a comic who
has been married for a long time has
kids they're kind of growing up was kind
of like married before he started making
money as a comedian and that was like
his priority was family and that's what
he wanted and uh he just helped me he
kind of was my like he was like my
maverick he guided me in with that like
he helped me get the ring he showed me
where to go
he talked me through the feelings like
on the night i was gonna propose
this is
honest to god truth i felt everything in
my body was like i just want to leave
wow i just wanted to get in the car and
drive like thelma louise i don't even
know where i was going drive away i just
wanted to drive away i didn't want to do
it every fear hit me
and then i did it
and it felt incredible
it was incredible
when i did it but
it was the opposite before i could
couldn't sit still in my skin like i was
just i could feel that oh god i was just
uncomfortable i wanted to leave i wanted
to get out of my body out of the
situation
but okay so you have those feelings but
was it telling you the situation is
wrong
the feeling was telling the situation is
wrong everything's wrong i was doing
everything but it was just the fear of
commitment it was a fear of commitment
it was the fear of the choice i was
making which i knew would have
consequences that was something outside
of myself and it has to do with my
issues growing up and uh it's hard it's
hard to face that [ __ ] that's the
scariest thing i could ever think of
yeah and look marriage is like
it's it's work
but it's like stand-ups work too right
and we love stand-up we love comedy it's
work sometimes
um but like flying on planes and doing
all that shit's work but then when we're
on stage that's the good part so it's
like it's real our love for stand-up is
real and i look at my love for my wife
and i'm like it's real you know we fight
uh we have different opinions
but
overall like we support each other all
the good you get out of it
is just puts everything in perspective
about everything else is not being
important and like it's family you have
a new family yeah and family never
leaves
and
you have a womb you're like you have a
cozies place you have a cozy place where
you can she's asleep like you know i go
down in
the basement i put my hand on my balls i
watch a game and i feel i'm at home
and that's just a nice feeling even if
she's not with me which sometimes is
nice
yeah jesus more rooms that's why it's
like
[ __ ] mormons basements upper
basements yeah and then when you have a
kid it's like
that's the thing man i mean i hate to be
so cynical about it but no this is all
interesting because i feel a lot of
these things a lot of people do i think
i mean even when i'm watching your
special and the talking about the
wedding and stuff and just a lot it's
like [ __ ]
when you have a kid
uh you realize what the meaning of life
is it's pretty
cynical it's no different than a string
bean or a cockroach it's like the
meaning of life is kind of just like to
reproduce that's what all animals are
doing and when you do it it's like
nature you don't even have a choice you
just have these feelings of you know
you're loving something more than
yourself and then you're like everything
just feels easier because like oh you're
like oh that's that's what it's about
you're a little like oh this is [ __ ]
this isn't
this it's pretty cynical like there's no
like
great philosophy to figure out or no
apex feeling it's just like to give
to her or him or they or baby or
whatever your kid i do them yeah it's
just one but yeah yeah we only have one
seat yeah
but uh that that takes you out of
yourself so maybe anything that takes
you out of yourself oh yeah makes you
happy
something bigger than you or outside of
you yeah that's the root of a lot of
recovery stuff too is just feeling
better is just getting out of yourself i
i respect addicts the most in fact i
tell my really good friend who's an
addict that he's my role model and i
mean that because i know what he has to
do i know what he has to go through and
he's built a family and he's sober and
just being sober and that he works out
so much and put his addiction in another
place it's just i know how hard what he
does is i know what he's going through i
have people very close to me who have
who have
lost that battle for now
in big ways that are painful
um and then him to be able to day by day
he's just my role that strength for me
like that's who i look up to
like i look up to him really it has
nothing to do with career or anything
like that it's like you know i know he's
he's fighting that battle and i i just i
have all the respect for people who have
to do who go through that you know i'm
lucky enough it's just lucky that you
don't have that yeah it's like my dad my
dad told me he he was very cynical but
he told me everyone
it's luck most of life is luck and that
was very disconcerting here as a young
person but the way he explained is like
even if you have your health like even
michael jordan you go oh michael jordan
that's not luck that's it yeah yeah yeah
it is but like he's lucky he didn't get
hit by a car right he's lucky we're
always lucky if we're like healthy or
like you know nothing bads happen
because we don't control that [ __ ]
yeah right [ __ ] shooter come in here
right now and end us yeah you already
got shot yeah
so at this point
probably going to be your boy right here
yeah bro the chances happens twice i
don't want that no you don't want that
but yeah i can just totally man my whole
life i've had that commit that when it
comes to relationships and stuff like
that commitment you know like not even
never wanting to be totally attached to
somebody else you know like
even my girlfriends i would introduce
them a lot of times by their first i
would just say this is my friend or this
is like i would never want to [ __ ]
have somebody else
have a say in who i was you know
um
that means you're independent you're
strong it does but it's also about
commitment like you know it's really
about
that's true some of it could be
independence but i think some of it's
about like um
yeah i just want to be totally stand on
my own and i don't want if somebody
thinks something of that person
i don't want to them think of it like
it's like i have some
you don't want to
negatively reflect on you right yeah
which is kind of a crazy selfish way to
think it's not even it's not a choice i
make it's something that was baked into
me right you know it's something that i
know isn't healthy or conducive to
feeling okay
isn't it weird how we're like these
sensitive like of this all the species
we're like this
this most sensitive with feelings and
freudian issues like a turtle doesn't
think about his childhood yeah turtle's
not like my mom didn't
but it's very valid for humans it's
weird
like they don't have issues
they don't need therapy animals don't
need therapy yeah it's that's why
sometimes i'm like are we this loose end
of existence that's not are we like the
appendix you know are we like this thing
that wasn't supposed to be there like
you know like the show lost kind of are
we like the thing that
wasn't supposed to happen if you lined
all the animals and stuff up like we
kind of fit in a little yeah but we're
definitely the outsider for sure big
time we need pavement we need toilets
yeah that's a good question maybe this
is just an evolutionary mistake like a
you know like a byproduct of like that
uh evolutionary will that carries
species
through time and uh into survival and
maybe we're just uh yeah maybe we're
just a product of that will and then
you're like ah well
the end result of that is not supposed
to be
what it is because we've because we kind
of mastered it all the other animals
still have some weaknesses but we're
like superman of the species
yeah we're making shows about i mean
it's like we're like we're like
yes we're like yeah like we're making
shows about life
and we're like you're living it we're
like we're doing it twice right that way
yeah we're doing holograms we're
perfecting we're making it look perfect
even though it's not it's like
it's interesting man it's interesting to
think uh
yeah but then also i can feel a god a
lot of times i can feel that there's a
power that's greater than me you know
it's got to be so it's like
that
makes you think you're connected to
something else that there is some
purpose you know because i can i mean i
have no doubt that i feel a god you know
so i mean it's just my perception
maybe maybe that's what it's maybe we
evolved
in order to
to [ __ ] [ __ ] all the other species
who think they're the [ __ ] because they
walk around arrogant they're not humble
we're the only ones yeah right i mean
[ __ ] lions walk around like their
[ __ ] don't stink dude and it's like look
i get it you're beautiful they're so
beautiful they're [ __ ] killing
machines and they run [ __ ] but not
anymore
not anymore dude we'll get some fat lazy
trophy hunter who's a ceo over here who
wants to feel because he's got too much
who come and just shoot you for sport
damn so don't [ __ ] walk around like
all like it's not like that anymore it's
not all like that you can't be rolling
around the jungle like that so maybe we
like we get humbled by god maybe we're
their god and that's was our purpose
because they were [ __ ] acting up
maybe they were all sinning like why the
[ __ ] they got to be dicks like that why
does the hyena have to kill his his
brother and sister just to you know just
because he wants to be the bad one and
show his mother that he can survive more
why not why not help him why not find
out what he's good at he's your brother
yeah he's not as strong as you but maybe
he's good at puzzles or some [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah raccoons eat their children if
they want to have more sex they they're
probably going to hell that's bad that's
sinning they have to so maybe we were
like their god and be punishing them you
could easily if you open the door to
imagine you open the door to hell and
there aren't a million raccoons in there
you would have to be disappointed you'd
be like dude
they're allowed to do that and i'm going
to hell because i cheated on my math
test that would be that would be bad
dude there's a picture of some dogs
having sex when we're young and my
brother and i are both hugging one of
the dogs around the net
pretty cool wait say that again there's
a picture of two dogs mating our
neighbors dogs and my brother and i are
both hugging one of the dogs around the
neck we don't know that they're mating
oh okay i just think their buddies are
you know like yeah cause you said that i
was like best friends that that was
that's a that's a moment right there
yeah well they were [ __ ] you just
guys got in
great picture probably never never
happened yeah you might that might be
one of the only times two people hug two
animals while they were mating and got a
picture out of it yeah like that that's
one of those rare things you like to is
theo and his brother the only people who
did that who made that happen yeah you
could google that right now would not be
there that's one of those things
you could google most things that
something would come up i guarantee you
if he googles right now
two brothers hugging two animals [ __ ]
two brothers hugging two animals [ __ ]
zero comes up yeah brothers hugging uh
mating animals man mating animals
i told you
i told you
what's the closest thing we got is there
anything right there what's that picture
with the humans in it
nope no that's autism
damn
every time they sneak that autism hug in
there baby damn every time baby damn
i love if there's anything like
human hugging [ __ ]
human hugging sex animals it's always
autism
let's hit a couple news topics and then
we'll get giannis out of here you got to
make sure to catch his special mom love
i can only vouch for the first 34
minutes of it but man it was awesome
dude thank you and thank you for saying
that thank you for having me i really i
appreciate it this is the way to like
get the word out and like you got a big
audience so i appreciate you having me
man yeah it's cool man i'm glad to get
to meet you and spend time with you
um
yeah i can't believe we haven't over the
years kind of but then once podcast has
started people don't see each other as
much in a weird way yeah
yeah yeah i guess so and there was
always kind of the west coast east coast
thing that kind of kept people apart i
guess you guys would come in and do on a
and that's how you'd meet some east
coast oh that's true yeah and otherwise
like yeah that there was just that
separation podcast has kind of bridged
that gap a little bit that's a good
point well we started doing podcasts
because we saw how rich you guys were
getting
oh people were thinking that yeah oh
hell yeah yeah well the ones of us who
are [ __ ]
you know
have some smarts at least you're going
jesus christ not only are they
making money but they're having a blast
yeah they're having a good [ __ ] time
like why would we
go do six sets a night you know to go
perform on some
late night show you know and when
nobody's watching well these guys are
having a great time yeah we were like
looking at a party we were like you know
like looking at that party going on and
we're like our party sucks but we didn't
want to admit that it sucks then finally
someone's got to go dude
just because it's our party we got to
stop thinking our party's great because
we want to depend defend our party
because you know it's like that thing
we're like i can make fun of my brother
but you can't yeah kind of thing like
even though i know he's stupid but i i
only i can say it you can't and then
you're going like dude just like join
the party man they're having a blast
they're making comedy they're having fun
they're talking to each other laughing
yeah and making a new type of comedy
this is a new thing like stand-up was a
thing that came along during vaudeville
when there was no technology we could
film anything and now it's like this is
a new thing it's like a mixture of like
improv riffing stand up uh i don't know
what it is but it's not just radio it's
not just
uh like
jokes it's like a it's a podcast it's a
new ethos
yeah and it's so i mean there's so many
now too it's like i mean a few years ago
there was literally even three years ago
and it i feel like it like doubles the
the amount of them doubles i wonder how
often
because it's crazy like people years ago
that were like i remember crystal he was
like i'm never doing a [ __ ] podcast i
remember amy schumer was like
poo poo
you know and then now everybody's done
one
or if they can do one they do one yeah
you know yeah even people that's damn
rich i think biden does one they don't
even know he didn't even know if he does
one
crazy if you ask him he might say yes oh
dude
that freaking child predator yeah
um let's look at this right here oh did
you see this the man what is this about
this is the guy that attacked chappelle
says he was triggered yeah yeah what is
it
yeah which is it also says an apparent
change of an apparent change of tune
um
that seems like
attorneys probably told him to say this
huh
yeah that's a good call yeah yeah that
gives him much more of a leg to stand on
i feel like yeah it's like hey this will
get some people behind you
i thought this was fake actually when i
first heard about this
oh leah is quoted as saying i identify
as bisexual i wanted him to know what he
said was triggering
i wanted him to the next time he should
consider first running his material by
people it could affect could you imagine
no
the arrogance of that statement
well if this guy's buyer you know the
male side of him should have freaking
attacked him
attacked himself
well it's just i don't you can't you
can't
then you don't don't need to listen to
this man
go listen to a man or woman that you
didn't really enjoy i think right uh
i thought they hired somebody to do this
i really really did i also like thought
that with the slap you know hollywood's
911 the will smith and chris rockslap at
first i was like that's fake i think a
lot of people thought
because i guess a lot of people you know
we stayed [ __ ] now everything everyone's
got to make a spectacle
to uh online that's what it's become you
know yeah it's like uh because we
it gets views i mean the news even does
that right they just create a spectacle
with their headlines and they're
fear-mongering and all that because it
gets views we're all competing to get
attention so inevitably you're like did
they stage that for attention there's
always a
question in your brain
yeah and they beat the guy up pretty
good
um
but i even if i'm if i'm somebody i
don't have anything going on you're like
hey i'll give you a half a mil 200 000.
some guys are going to break a couple of
your bones can you handle it
if i'm already bisexual i'll probably
buy
joints or whatever sure i could probably
take a shoulder out of socket so you say
even though you got beat it there is a
chance it could still be
it could still be fake oh i i i'm not
saying that it definitely isn't but i
would not have been shocked i think you
could find a guy for 200 grand yeah that
would take a take an ass weapon and go
potentially he's not going to go to jail
do you think he'll go to jail
that's i heard he's getting out but i
mean it happened in los angeles right i
feel like that's what happens in los
angeles criminals get out yeah get off
now so i mean uh especially if he says
he was triggered by jokes i feel like
they'd go like oh we we must have had
the wrong guy
but then i guess if you're trans say if
you're trans and this guy isn't trans
well he doesn't say he says he's bi
but then this dude is like you're dang
he's like you're a
rudy rudiger kind of idiot
and you know what i'm saying like if
you're really on that side of the boat
he's like you're john brown he's uh i
don't know who john brown is john brown
was down from cleveland no john brown
was uh the dude who attacked the armory
to protest slavery he was down for the
like he did the crazy like kind of
suicide mission oh he did he attacked
the armory and
yeah he was like down for the cause but
it's are people like heroizing this guy
are the gay and trans community hero
heroising him i don't know that's a good
question i don't know
i don't know how they
i think he just came out
saying this
so maybe they're maybe they're having
their meeting now to figure out
how to praise him
maybe they're having their media meeting
to go like oh you know now we can
now we can like him i don't know what
they're doing oh yeah because he's
adding in also plus jokes earlier in the
night
made by an opener talking pedophilia
rocked lee as well he says he was
sexually abused as a minor
well that's one of the side effects of
being a damn minor these days i feel
like dude you got to get i mean you got
to get into a better industry if you
guys are underground somebody's going to
touch ass on the way up yeah i'm i'm
disconcerting how much of that is going
on like how much
i love how the guy's arm is out of sock
and they still cuff him
oh my god
dude the lord already cuffed this dude
seems a little redundant yeah i mean his
arm is backwards
how did they even get his arm back
normal
i mean it looks like he's an action
figure and like you pop it out
a different way that's 200 000 man they
spat on me and twisted me as if on
purpose
oh
yeah no they definitely they definitely
didn't do it on accident he said
no they
they didn't break your arm on accident
man
at least he's aware of that this is
interesting right here i told him my
mother and grandmother who fought for
his civil rights to be able to speak
would be upset at the things he said
this is a perfect example of what you
were talking about earlier where things
go kind of this full circle way where
it's like
you you want
what were you saying earlier you said
it's like you want to get these freedoms
but at a certain point they kind of like
get too free yeah it gets itself there's
nowhere to go
like uh yeah you're like dude
you know
you you know how
do you know how contradictory what
you're saying
you're saying my grandparents fought for
this right like yeah that's why he's a
multi-millionaire comedian speaking
freely right who's black right exactly
like that's the end of the right like
yeah that's at a certain point
that's you're doing you're doing what
the cops would do to him back then or
maybe sometimes now but you're doing
what like white america would have done
to him back then so what you're saying
makes no [ __ ] sense you're being the
bad person but he doesn't see that he
has an awareness of it yeah yeah he's
shutting down a black man doing comedy
getting paid millions of dollars having
being adorned by all these people who
have paid to see him you're stopping
that because uh
you think you're doing it for civil
rights it's twisted logic well it's
interesting because it's like what's the
thing then is it the vet the fact that
you don't want him to like
if the money's not involved then
it kind of changes it what do you mean
well i guess like
man it's so hard to think and say stuff
um
like
you want him to be able to speak um i
don't know what i'm saying exactly what
he was saying if the money's not
involved well it's like civil rights
like you want to you know freedom of
speech like you're granted he says my
grandmother fought for his freedom of
speech right right
so
now he has that freedom of speech right
but is it because he's making like why
did he do it what's his reasoning why he
did it
and what determines like is it what
determines if his speech is
free or not like at what point
is it the fact that he's making i don't
know what i'm saying exactly well i mean
the ridiculous thing is he's making
jokes right so that's a weird it means
your society's in a weird place
when the jesters are being attacked
because right this is specifically a
place where he's making jokes he's
making jokes man i mean he says on the
sign it's like this is a comedy show
it's a comedy weekend i mean
even this guy knows that i mean dave
chappelle is a comedian
dave chappelle does not work at a auto
body shop yeah he's a comedian everyone
knows who he is people aren't paying to
go watch him fix a car they're watching
him do jokes and so when comedians
are getting attacked you start going
like oh society may be getting a little
unhealthy because the kings
you know they would keep a gesture
around
to keep them honest to tell them the
truth with jokes that's what we do we
sugarcoat the truth a little bit so it's
like you know i just want to say like
hey maybe the gesture's right right
isn't that what we do we kind of put a
little candy over the truth like
you know yeah if you don't want to hear
the gesture anymore then that's a little
bit strange then there's something
something strange
something's off the society's not
healthy and it's the black community
keeps attacking their own kind yeah
which is bizarre that is bizarre um
all right what else we got any other
good news story came in
sometimes it's nice to podcast because i
don't think a deal with the rest of my
life isn't that crazy even though it's a
great life it's like just have to make
choices and do things i think the same
reason why you listen to a podcast or
watch a movie it's like sometimes it's
like
you just don't want to have to
i don't know i sound ungrateful no but i
know what you're saying is right now
you're in the moment you're not thinking
about yeah tough stuff yeah that's what
i'm saying yeah just not having to think
about tougher stuff you know my sister's
trying to buy a house i'm gonna help her
look at that it's like i'm gonna have to
make choices about
you know all cool stuff but it's like
it just feels like less responsibility
right now
well that's why the audience probably
connects with it so much because like
you said you're doing the same thing
they're doing
we're both taking a break yeah you're
taking a break the audience is taking a
break and when it's over it's like oh
now i gotta go help my sister buy a
house gotta get back to [ __ ]
yeah
there's probably someone watching right
now who also is helping their sister buy
out yeah that's true
what do we have here
yeah here's an interesting one new york
high court to determine if bronx zoo
elephant is a person why not why not
2022 why not
is it a person
i mean what is going on
has it paid taxes that's what i want to
know
i mean how would they even mix those two
up how would they
if it was a person how did they get how
did it get to a point where an article
needed to be written that they were
going to investigate whether it was true
how do you mistake those two things
one's like 10 tons the other is like 300
pounds if it eats fast food
it's a big difference
jesus christ says that uh
can she can the elephant be considered a
person a question was before new york's
highest court wednesday in a closely
watched case of whether a basic human
right can be extended to an animal oh so
it's more that okay it's more the rights
of the animal
they said it's in a one-acre prison
you know this goes back to like
black have you seen that movie black um
[Music]
black uh fish
it's about like black something happened
to black fish even like whenever
whales or whatever
with the zoo and they put him in there
in san diego and people got upset about
it
um
but it's like
do you think if you see a
like
the animal's safer in this space but is
it getting
its true
existence
i think that's the question and it's
almost the same thing we've been talking
about with humans it's like we're safer
in this space for sure there's bumpers
on everything there's insurance there's
lawyer there's you're as safe as you
could be you can buy braces through the
mail
a woman the other night had me sign her
little metal leg and it had like a
a little thing in it where it also sorts
coins on the side of it right like
we're living in a [ __ ] brook stone
right
but are we getting
the are we getting the most the most
natural experience that's almost what's
happening here right right is are we not
fulfilled is it the most fulfilling
yeah it's exactly what's happening here
yeah the non-human rights project wants
to move from a one-acre prison at the
zoo to a more spacious sanctuary
because with all these things they're
like just set them free
yeah well this doesn't even sound like
they're returning them to their natural
habitat where they beat this just seems
like they're getting uh they're just
they're upgrading they're from a condo
to a mansion
to have more spacious you know
they'd still have that same safety or
whatever yeah i'd say maybe the
more humane thing ironically would be to
put them back into the
being an elephant yeah is suited for
nature where it can look around you know
because elephants can intimidate lions
you know yeah and that probably makes
them feel good and now they don't have
that that's taken away you know
that must build an elephant self-esteem
when lions come around and be like you
know we're hungry we may take you down
yeah an elephant goes dude i'm 10 tons
you can try it
but i may stomp one of you yeah it's
gonna be bad for somebody yeah
is something gonna come down and say hey
you guys are doing it wrong right go
back to uh
but here's the weird thing if we went
back
wouldn't we try to get back here to be
safer i don't know that's the thing and
who what or who would keep you in line
to
yeah like if someone came up like if we
had to survive against
predators that were trying to kill us
like back in the day like hyenas
saber-toothed tigers and then there was
a dude who figured out a way to like
effectively keep them at bay who would
be would there be a
some sort of judge that came and be like
dude dude you can't advance that much
right we got to keep it like that but
then even having that judge is kind of
advanced
so it's a it's a you can't get out of
the quagmire it's a you can't escape it
we're always going to try to
find a smart way to outsmart these
predators and that makes us more human
and softer because we use our brain
that's what we have
gorilla's got strength
right this is almost is this the best
case scenario where we are dude if we're
just left to deal with predators with
jiu-jitsu
i don't know how effective it would be
because that's essentially what we're
advocating for one more generation we'll
have some freaking gangsters out there
i think so probably yeah people are
we're they're getting some talent man
john jones could beat a lot of animals
you think so yeah i think so for a
second yeah for for a little bit man
i think um
there's room i mean there's old stories
of dustin fourier beating you know 20
raccoons outside of a bar in uh in
lafayette he tried to get jumped by
raccoons bro it's a dangerous game down
there i'm just saying look there's a
there is
there's a lot of i think mythology out
there about humans fighting animals yeah
the greeks used to have a lot of it did
they yeah fighting animals
yeah because we tr i mean they try like
or is this the best is this where we are
obviously this is where we are this is
we would probably just do this again i
know what you're saying you're basically
saying we overdid it where we took the
fun out of it we took like the game out
of it which makes you like think and
immerses you in the game of like
survival because now we can just nuke
predators that's too much uh it's not
fair it's not fair man i always like the
idea that people can do uh like if
somebody wants to fight an animal with a
knife or something i think that's fair
you know i don't sometimes with the hunt
and stuff i'm not an anti-hunter at all
like
but i would love to see more
hand-to-hand combat with animals
that would be great that would be great
to see yeah it's a fair fight i feel
like we'd lose a lot though it's my only
problem hell yeah we would do this every
week there's a video some guy lose into
a goose at a damn local watering hole
yeah there's some guy's kid getting his
one of his ears nipped off by a damn uh
gosling or whatever yeah i mean even if
the gazan cuts weight
it's still unfair
it's still [ __ ] it's got that animal
strength always got the advantage and
that's why i think like we'll always
invent a knife yeah in order to compete
or else we go extinct
like dude you know what the crazy [ __ ]
is we were not the apex predator for
most of our existence only the past
couple thousand years did we figure some
[ __ ] out but for like hundreds of
thousands of years
[ __ ]
we got eaten wow we didn't figure it out
until we teamed up with dogs
they they they they ran they did a lot
of the recon they did recon for us and
like yo bad shit's coming we hid
whatever we need and they fought off
lions for us and [ __ ] and then we were
able to they gave us some time to sit
around and think about it figure [ __ ]
out build a knife because you can't
figure out how to build a knife when
you're constantly being hunted yeah you
can't think it's not a moment to think
it's like having anxiety all the time
you can't
you know you can't do your best work
when you're anxious
so oh amen man
amen dude i feel that yeah at a deep
level dude um janice thanks so much for
coming man thank you man cool bro i
really really appreciate it nice to meet
you on camera chat yeah nice it was a
fun ride yeah yeah it's been a lot of
fun and you can check out his special
mom love it's on youtube right now and
um he's got some amazing characters um
that you gotta watch on youtube as well
i know they're old and i mean you may
feel past those in some ways or whatever
i i but yeah man so crazy bro you gotta
go watch uh
watch some more giannis papas if you're
not familiar with them and um
yeah man thank you so much for coming on
dude thank you i appreciate it yeah
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself
that online on me
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
pants
and these wells that i've been riding on
they want something that they're damn
they're
just